energy get the energy keep sustained
that sense of energy great energy and
achieve energy
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can raise your
energy and as always if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave in the comments below and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well enjoy when I started
Microsoft I didn't think of it as all
that risky I mean I was so excited about
what we were doing it's true I could
have gone bankrupt
but you know I had a set of skills that
were highly employable and in fact my
parents were still willing to let me go
back to Harvard and finish my education
if I wanted to you've always got a job
with a bellman and the only the thing
that was scary to me wasn't quitting and
starting the company it was when I
started hiring my friends and they
expected to be paid and and then we had
customers who went bankrupt customers
that I'd counted on to come through and
so then I got this incredibly
conservative approach that I wanted to
have enough money in the bank to pay a
year's worth of payroll even if we
didn't get any any payments coming in
and I'm almost heard about the whole
time we have about 10 billion now which
is pretty much enough for the next year
anyway you know I if you're going to
start a company it takes so much energy
that you know you it better overcome
your your feeling of risk I don't think
that you necessarily if you're going to
start a company should do it at the
start of your career I think there's a
lot to be said for working for a company
learning how they do things you know if
you're young it's hard to go lease
premises they made that hard for me you
couldn't rent a car when you were under
25 at the time so I was always taking
taxis to go see customers and the people
would you know people say we're going to
go have a discussion in the bar well I
could go to the bar and you know that's
fun because I'll tell you when people
are first skeptical and then go this kid
doesn't know anything then when you show
them you've really got a good product
you know something they actually tend to
go overboard and they think whoa you
know they know a lot let's really do an
incredible amount with these people so
our youth at least in this country was a
huge asset for us once we reached a
certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people because they'll
be a little bit conservative about
whether they should come in and take the
risk and it took three or four years
before we could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come with starting to firm
you better think of those as as part of
the the pleasure part of the the
challenge that that is part of the the
excitement what do you think the biggest
difference between doing a play and
doing I mean it's a cliched question but
I'd be interested to know your answer I
think a part of what viola just said is
that you get to dig deeper and you get
another day and you get the energy you
do a movie and it's 200 people that are
used to it and then okay
everybody's doing their job and it comes
in a theater somewhere and you know you
picking your nose at home somewhere
couldn't open your nail there's no
energy right when I was on Broadway five
years ago Julius Caesar I made a
decision to sign autographs every night
kind of what I did really having this
time only as I rub my knees only because
my knees are bad it's harder for me to
stand but why did you decide to do it
well you know I wanted to say thank you
uh-huh it was my way of saying thank you
and the first night it was like five
people out that's okay way to me
everybody who has played bills from our
show like people were just watering up
the block I forgot I'm on 42nd Street
but honestly reciting for we energy and
I was out there hour and a half every
night every show but the energy you got
back two stories to five little old
ladies who who just drove in from
Detroit and I'm like well what y'all
doing tonight and we getting back in the
car baby we got to go back tonight and
you know a little 84 year old lady was
like baby if I was three years younger
then we had and I say this also because
I hope it happens with this plate we had
some high schools come we had one school
from somewhere I forgot where and they
were doing Julius Caesar and some young
kid was like well you know my Buddhist
is a bit different
[Music]
he's more the classic stoic and what it
was great to engage in in exchange with
these young people with it was there was
an energy I got more from it than I gave
to to the people that I signed for
that's you know you don't get that you
know the odd thing about success in film
is the budgets get bigger you make more
money but they become more formulaic so
you don't get the opportunity so I got
willing if I stay around long enough
this is what I'm gonna be doing one of
the things that are people talk a lot
about is what gets someone to become an
entrepreneur I mean I you know it's just
a fascinating mindset right you really
have to be slightly delusional hard to
be a star you know an entrepreneur
because you have to suspend disbelief
you all you have to believe about your
own idea and have deep passion to go
pursue it so in some sense quite
honestly before I leave advise I take a
lot of inspiration from what you're
doing now it takes a lot of guts
it takes a lot of energy to be an
entrepreneur and I think that in the end
there therein lies I think your secret
to success which is your ability to
overcome every constrain and every
obstacle and not and do it with the
boldness and the risk on nature of it I
think is fantastic if anything I would
say especially for entrepreneurs is you
might keep sustained that sense of
energy over a long period of time
because we all know and you are grounded
in it the mortality rate is superhot uh
and that means you will be
throwing curveballs you know day in and
day out uh and you have to be able to
overcome that and so being a source of
energy in your small team especially if
you're a CEO of a start-up I like to
sort of observe them a lot because uh
you can't have a bad day you know all
the time you know you get up in the
morning you're coding in the afternoon
you're talking to your investors in the
evening you're you know hiring and
that's constant sense of energy and
passion for what you're doing is what I
think it takes and to never give up
which is what makes you who you are in
terms of the core makeup and I think
that for me I am personally inspired by
all that and I think that even from a
Microsoft culture that's what my dream
is like it's not that okay we have you
know a large organization my hope is
that every team inside of Microsoft
feels booked that sense of energy and
empowerment and goes about it do you
have moments of repose moments of just
I'll just take it in and sit quietly nah
you know I got it I have to do a lot of
plane flies yeah and I oh I'm a handful
I don't know why I haven't made it in
the tabloids as the bloke who started
the riots and stuff on the planes yet
but I guarantee you it will happen you
know you can't you can't hang your arm
out the window and you can't stop and
have a pee and look at the wildlife yeah
you know you're stuck in this thing for
like sometimes 14 hours in a leg you
know like going to America's just it's a
14-hour stint mate that's shocking awful
to sit there and all that you know you
can't I'm just I like a good movie but
not five of them in a row
and I don't read much you know like I'm
just you don't read
how come you know like well I do read
but no you know like God not for 14
hours
you know surf mags take a good 20
minutes
the place
to me I like I like the live stuff
there's stuff on the album because stuff
on the album Seymour the left no say you
gotta have a certain tone I'm saying
[ __ ] me but I don't get too excited
she'll let it flow but when your fade
sweat pours there I'm a big one too
sweaty drenching I'll just be
representing you know sales doing my
thing y'all necklace I'm going up black
night so when they want to sue your
windpipe slow do you run out of energy
emotionally I'm not sleepy this is Neil
this is me on no sleep right now um I
don't I keep I can't express how happy
of a person I am I can't express how
inspiring in ah I guess you can say
motivating my life and the people around
me are you know things work in the
moment and then can die off and then
things cannot work in one moment and
come to life and if you have any wisdom
whatsoever you know to follow you know
wherever there is great energy and
that's what I followed with Denis when
we did enemy I went this guy's great
energy we vibe on each other and this I
got to go with this like I don't know
what this movies about but I know but I
know this energy and I know this energy
is success somewhere creative success
and that's first and foremost to me and
that's what I follow now and that energy
drives a movie when you watched as an
audience it's infectious when you see
that on the screen and I see it all the
time with people your ear you're
infected by that energy and that's what
we want we average about 200 about 250
to 275 concerts per year
sometimes that mean you might do two in
one day
I'm 69
70 and September the 16th if I live that
long
and I find the energy meeting people
like yourselves I enjoy people I love to
play see people happy I love to see them
dance see them enjoy themselves that's
energy for man it's education I get a
chance to learn out of sand
merci beaucoup I don't speak French but
Lucille does music is a universal
language and I believe that because it's
been many times I've heard great
musicians like Django Reinhardt I love
never ham speak English but he speaks it
with his guitar so I think music is a
universal language that we can I believe
communicate with anyone
I think of energy in its and any when
wasn't - this is very important when you
stop wave I delete it we see it 43 44
years of age they see the energy the
Piercy then you see bonus and oye but
when you get to the sixes they still
expect to see it so I look at myself in
terms of energy that it was a slept
because when I was a young major four or
five years no problem when I got to that
to the 60s and either six or seven hours
so you go to bed air where you look at
your your diet better sardine eat
swallow after the game on home you know
I never a very very seldom learners are
innate so that added things I myself of
my energy because people want to see the
energy very important aspect of it you
know
[Music]
I always envisioned myself and your
being a rapper and being in the game and
having success but you never know what
it really feels like or how you're going
to be when you're there
[Music]
[Applause]
and then whisk comes from me being the
youngest dude in my age group of people
that hung out with it would call me a
young Wiz you know like always wise
beyond my years and the Khalifa is
Arabic it means successor leader shining
light my granddad gave me that name
he's um actually Muslim so you know he's
to see my path and that I was doing it
how hard I was working and he gave me
our name and I'll just put the two
together
of course I do write music and I'm a
hip-hop artist but as an individual as a
personality and what I give to the
people I see myself as like the lead
singer of a band or something you know
when I go out there I'm a real performer
it's all about the vibe and the feeling
you got to be balanced and it's like
nothing that I have to put on I really
feel you know that energetic and that
happy to be in front of their kids thank
you guys so much for watching I'd love
to know what did you think did you get
your energy raise from watching this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that you want to apply
to your life or your business
immediately what's the first action step
that you're going to take to apply it
leave in the comments below
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout at the best.you pro
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and taking that
awesome picture on Twitter and posting
it I really really really really
appreciate it thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon